world semi-final
top esports versus sooning gaming it was
one of the most important matches of the
tournament
but not for the reason you might think
that match was a faded reunion of two
players from one of league of legends
most
important teams put your hands together
for the flash wolves
as members of the flash wolves they
ruled the lms winning seven straight
titles
and now carson and swordart's final test
for a shot at the summoner's cup
was each other casa is going to set
himself
up with a showdown against sword art
while most fans memory of the flash
wolves starts in 2015
the team actually goes back all the way
to 2013 under a team that
some old school league fans might
remember the gammania
bears
2013 world championship run was short
and
forgettable they played one best of
three series against future world
champions sk telecom t1
got swept and then pieced out of the
tournament after worlds 2013 the entire
germania bears roster
aside from their jungler moved over to
what would become their new home for
years flash wolves but the flash wolves
didn't return to international
competition
until 2015 when they added a young
jungler named carson
carson replaced refrain on the flash
rules roster during the second split of
the
inaugural lms season and their results
improved immediately
i think carso really kind of broke that
equation where
uh the mid jungle wasn't necessarily
better from flash roles
compared to everyone else once castle
landed on the team the mid-jungle
was the definite gold standard in the
entire region
flash wolves won iem taipei that year
which qualified them for the iem world
championship where they made it to the
semi-finals after knocking
out cloud 9 and sk gaming in groups only
forgiven standing between sk and
elimination
there go the nexus turrets there goes
the nexus and the yowie flash wills will
move on to the semifinals gg
and at worlds that year they shocked
everyone
oh snap gopher and now he misses it the
lantern out the dark passage is huge
gorilla goes down immediately he doesn't
even really get slicing maelstrom off
right back into prey kick him in the
mouth take him down one more time the
sigil coming out a double kill in now
for maple on his laplace two games in a
row and now coming up with more big
kills
smeb going for the victory the valiant
fight before he goes down
kuro should get critted out here few
more hits he
cannot shift himself to safety and flash
wolves onto nexus are going to take down
the coup
tigers the flash wolves got first in
their group at worlds that year by
beating the coup tigers the lck's second
seed and a tournament
favorite twice in a row and this was
back when korean teams looked
untouchable
suddenly the whole world was paying
attention to flash wolves
sword art looked like an elite support
karsa was styling and other junglers in
his group
and maple was dominating the competition
if a barrel explodes on multiple people
oh maybe a catch gorilla does combo into
stake chain though out gangplank
is going to zone them away this is not a
bad fight for the flash rules but the
ulti outbreak
although they were knocked out by origen
in the quarterfinals flashlight back
home with notoriety and experience and
that's when the flash wolves complete
and utter domination
of the lms began
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
the flash wolves just kept getting
better and better karsa was a monster in
the jungle and sword art just kept
looking like a better and better leader
for the team with amazing shot calling
and great
engages i think the most important thing
was the
the voice that he provided that he was
essentially the coach
on the field at the time now in terms of
his qualities
as a player i think he was the sole part
of the engages on that team so sword art
had a very very
vital playstyle to him because the team
basically relied on him to get the fight
starting
and a lot of times he had to play very
very creatively to do that but maple
continued to shine the brightest
proving he was one of the best mid
laners in the world maple was the core
player on the flash wolves and he was a
reason that they were so dominant
because
no one else really even came close to
him
there was a lot of excellence on that
team from the coaching squad to all the
players
but if you really substitute maple out
with any other mid laner
i don't think flash wolves dynasty
exists thanks to their spring win the
flash wolves headed to china to compete
at the mid-season invitational
and it's there that they cemented their
place as korea's kryptonite
but they have to defend the super creeps
from the top and mid lane
this inhibitor now falling down nl
getting some cheeky auto attacks they've
managed to break their way through
one nexus turret separates skt from a
lobster flashlight
and he goes sword out massive three-man
pulverizes wolf
he's almost destroyed landers fight is
there an skt
relegated oh my god maple
they're going for broke on this one now
they turn their attention to take him
out
and the cow gets a pinball off onto duke
and blank just enough damage to take
down the tree
nexus turret number two is gonna fall
and faker is trying to save the day
chrono breaking back to stop sword art
but not enough and then i'll chasing
blank all the way back into fountain
fakers push back a double kill for edo
flash wolves have done it again
flash will prove that they could do what
no other team in the world could
consistently
and that earned them the korean team
killer nickname
it's such a great tournament for flash
wolves this is the second time in a row
they've actually two-owed a korean team
in a group stage
they two-owed at the time the coup
tigers at worlds in 2015 and now
they have two-owed the champions of that
tournament the flash wolves were poised
to make the finals
but once again they were unable to win a
single series
at an international tournament flash
wolves trying their damnedest
to prevent this and stay alive for one
last game but it's not going to happen
sk telecom g1 will face counter logic
gaming at the mid-season invitational
finals
for both teams to get their first chance
at their championship win tomorrow
this would end up becoming a bit of a
recurring theme for the flash wolves
they would dominate the lms
sweep a korean team in groups at an
international tournament and
then get knocked out in a best-of-five
series and head home
i think flash wolves as a team they were
you know a little sometimes a little bit
arrogant or sometimes a little bit
carefree
because they were so dominant in their
own domestic um
domestic scenarios you know these this
was not a team that faced a lot of
setbacks
in terms of their domestic performance
as the flash rules continued to falter
on the international stage
fans began to wonder how much longer
this team could really stick together
after all the lpl was right next door
and china had stronger competition
and fatter contracts to draw in players
and at the end of 2017
after the team failed to make it out of
groups at worlds the flashworld dynasty
saw his first crack carsa and stake were
the first names to
leave the team and head to the lpl maple
and sword art decided to stay but
the story didn't change they dominated
the lms
swept the reigning lck champions in
groups at msi
and then got knocked out in their first
best of five quarter finals
gets the kill and now moojin against the
world his own country now to talk him
down
to push him back out of the fountain and
the minions are here
the nexus is alone and king zone in the
return to form
will take the 3-1 victory over flash
wolves
at the end of 2018 after failing to make
out of groups at worlds again
maple and sword art decided to join
carsa in the lpl
with that the flash wolves that everyone
had fallen in love with was
no more and the only international title
to their name was a 2017 iem world
championship
sure the org kept on existing in the lms
and they even won another championship
with their new roster
but the damage was done at the end of
2019 the flash wolves ceased all
operations in league of legends but it
wasn't all
sad the remnants of the flash wolves
spread across the lpl
with players and coaches joining teams
all across china
the lpl marked a new era for these
players a chance to see if they could
reach even greater heights by
themselves kenavi is still dead for
another 30 seconds
it is a 5v4 on the map sword art with
the hook under the blitzcrank won't be
able to find the kill all the way
but zoe's artillery will guarantee it
zoom nearly gonna be killed off now
lamb's respite keeps sword art alive and
sooning will take down both
nexus turrets they are in a 5v3 on the
map
they are in a situation to take this
game and shooting
will take down their opponents from the
lpl
the third seed will defeat the second
and they will move on to the semi-final
casa is going to set himself up
with a showdown against sword art
and self-made will be the final kill
the final nail in the coffin and the
final blow
for fnatic top esports for the first
time
we'll pull off the reverse sweep top
esports will face off against sooning
in the semi-finals and now we're back
where we started
carsa vs sword art world's 2020
semi-finals the furthest
either player had ever made it at worlds
carso was now on the team that everyone
had pegged to win
worlds top esports while sword art led
the young sooning gaming roster as the
tournament's dark horse
and now the only thing standing between
them and the biggest grand finals of
their lives
was each other
[Music]
this match was the culmination of
everything swordart and carson had
learned in those last few years playing
a part
they were no longer the same players
they were when they were teammates on
the flash wolves
and now they had to show each other just
how much they changed
500 gold's gonna be claimed no problem
top esports knows better than to try
but the outer turrets are easy the more
difficult part is mid tier two
as they dunk right into it and instantly
one fung is gone
carsa makes the huge play in the mid
game i mean so far so good in in this
one here as well and
if if carson ever does show up oh that's
a there's a flash kick is this slow in
the juan phong he's trying to get away
but where are you going to go flash is
into immediately slowed then stun then
cleanses q's gonna come in and shockwave
finally guarantees a nice big pick means
the bot laner is gone
what's the timing and everything but now
another fight into the bottom side
shields come back out dracula forced to
cleanse he's actually running out of
health now
they are charging in he's got a flash
away to safety with a flash stun for
sword art and first blood comes through
trade it back though
still got a very very tight gold game
but i take the dragons more
potential now knight gonna get found out
can he get there in time he's trying and
he chomps them but there's still gonna
be too much damage
stopwatch buys another couple of seconds
but how do you live how could you
possibly
safety right he's got his tv they're
trying for a little something at least
369 is here tom catcher for the top as
well they're going to find a double stun
but this could be the fight 369 finds
the double knock up qss flash comes out
of one fun here comes angel
saves jack lift for a second but
youngjae gonna be careful can they get
round two they have the lock and shields
is it enough jackie let's kill sword art
as over the top finds two angel is low
can they find angel no knock up but it's
not for juan fung he finds one looks for
another they're gonna get jackie love
there is no damage left knight has to do
it all they get angel he's gotta run
knight has to run cars has to try can
they get the damage no one else is on
the base it is at the 3v3
carson drops that's sorry it's time for
running away but knight is already gone
and this could be enough
juan fung tries to take down 369 and
does so karsa
is gone as well that is the ace
and soon ning have done the impossible
g2 and groups jd gaming and quarters
and t-e-s and semis the most impressive
run of worlds so far and it belongs to
sooning
karsa and sword arts showdown proves
just how influential the flash wolves
still are
even when the team doesn't exist anymore
and it's not just former flash wolves
players making an impact
stake is coaching high-profile lpl teams
now like rng and lng
and another former flatulence coach
warhorse won the freakin world
championship last year as fpx's head
coach
flash wolves may be gone but their
legacy lives on
through players and coaches who continue
to do incredible things in league of
legends
and they leave behind a legacy that
continues to inspire smaller teams
i think what flashfolds represents
is the ability for lesser regions to
overcome
they basically drew out a template for
how teams that have less resources and
less talent most of the times
can still come out on top yeah
it's up to you if you want to hang out
for the shoot hang out if not you're
free to bail
oh my god
[Music]
[Music]
thanks
cool